princess beatrice married italian  property developer  eduardo mapelli matzi on friday  the newlyweds posed with queen elizabeth  and prince phillips social distancing at  all saints chapel in windsor  the princess borrowed her dress from her  grandmother the queen  who wore it in 1962. that queen mary  diamond fringe tiara  is the same one queen elizabeth wore on  her wedding day  in 1947. there are also similarities  between beatrice's gown and the one worn  by her mother sarah ferguson  with the puff sleaze and the beaded  bodice and how sweet is this  the groom shared this intimate shot on  his instagram with a poem that read  in part i carry your heart i carry it  in my heart  [Music]